[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
tu nous
les étoiles sont donnés
de monsieur marc
ag
as sur l'épaule
les combos mais ne sont pas un homme
je vois des gars là
[Musique]
tous
tous les deux étaient toutes mères
en
ce sera
[Musique]
je
c
à l'étoile open m
et
[Musique]
je cause
au pays demain
allez
du matin je cautionnais
tu te vois cecconi dans les basses
couches et acide
juste à tour un sort à bateaux
[Musique]
c'est rien dans tout nous est terminée
oh
on consomme surtout
pas pour
si
tous les doutes
en vue
[Musique]
merci
e
m
et pas plus
ok
m
du matin je collectionne
[Musique]
au pire demain vrai et
du matin je cause
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
thiam à chiens merci m c'est nous
il ya des fois on sait pas fort ah ouais
c'est pas fort c'est très très fort lui
et je suis actif total je t'ai pris ça
je pensais que je pourrais te faire
plaisir
[Rires]
il ya aussi son effet de serre en
sortons joie un chocolat et elle a été
repérée par bouba et il est très fort
pour le sait la mignonne radon rejoindre
dans un instant et en plus c'était sur
ton manager yes mexès que j'aime voilà
je suis moi je lui dirai tout à l'heure
j'ai vu c'est complètement différent de
ce qu'il fait mais il y avait des liens
jeux sony c'est du très lourd merci
beaucoup merci à global de me faire
venir ici merci à toi chérie a passé la
famille
reviens quand tu veux quand tu veux
en avril et ont tout cas être au ballon
c'est une merveille absolue et j'adore
franchement j'adore elia qu'on peut dire
merci chérie tu reviens nous
[Applaudissements]